ein niederschmetternder rekord die
deutschen exporte brechen um mehr als 30
prozent ein
mit folgen für die ganze wirtschaft eine
frage der funktion in seiner rolle als
innenminister darf horst seehofer die
afg nicht als staats zersetzend
bezeichnend urteilt das
bundesverfassungsgericht und eine
inselgruppe will es wagen ab montag
dürfen knapp 11.000 deutsche auf die
balearen reisen als test für die
urlaubssaison in corona zeiten
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers namen zu ihren
nachrichtenüberblick und danke dass sie
bei uns sind das schon mal vorweg
kristin otto ist mit dabei für den sport
nachher auch heute sehr geehrten guten
abend und wir beginnen mit einer zahl
die aufhorchen lässt ganz besonders in
einem land dessen wirtschaft so stark
vom export abhängt wie die deutsche um
knapp ein drittel ist der wert der
warenausfuhren abgestürzt der grösste
export einbruch in der
nachkriegsgeschichte
die folgen der korona krise schlagen
voll durch schauen wir uns die details
mal an
im april verkauften die deutschen
unternehmen nur noch waren im wert von
rund 75 milliarden euro ins ausland das
sind 31,1 prozent weniger als im
gleichen monat im vorjahr und das obwohl
die grenzen langsam wieder öffnen und
die konjunktur vorsichtig anzieht auch
aufs gesamte jahr gerechnet drohen dem
export desaströse zahlen andreas linke
harte metall werkzeuge zum fräsen stellt
die firma horn in tübingen hier kunden
sind zum beispiel automobil oder
maschinenbau branche in der krise das
sah man bereits im april als für horn
zuletzt besuchten fertigungs stillstand
das inlandsgeschäft war um 40 prozent
zurückgegangen die exporte sogar um 52
wobei april nicht die talsohle war wie
es allgemein prognose heißt für uns war
wirklich der monat mai die talsohle also
im bereich vom export waren die
rückgänge war noch mal um einen kleinen
truppe größer fast 55 prozent export -
im mai bei horn jetzt im juni sehen sie
ein hoffnungspflänzchen ohnehin fallen
die zahlen je nach produkt und branche
unterschiedlich aus motorsägen von stihl
etwa sind weltweit gefragt das
unternehmen aus dem schwäbischen
waiblingen ließ aber auch im april
wieder im märz und april
hatten wir dann rückgänge von nur 10
erwartet hatten wir viel mehr und dem
mai konnten wir schöne 25 prozent plus
zu buche
nach der finanzkrise vor zwölf jahren
half der export der deutschen wirtschaft
speziell in den asiatischen raum
doch dort ist diesmal ebenfalls krise
es wird sicherlich noch dauern bis der
export sich wieder erholt das hat damit
zu tun dass in anderen ländern den krise
eben noch da ist viele menschen haben
einkommen verloren und kaufen sich jetzt
kein neues auto auch die firmen warten
ab bevor sie neu investieren
deutschlands export zahlen vom april ein
jähes ende
nach zehn jahren außenhandels buchen und
da frage noch mal nach bei valerie
haller in frankfurt weil der region
abend ist das jetzt der tiefpunkt also
das tal und es gibt auch anzeichen dafür
dass es dann wieder aufwärts geht oder
hat das massive folgen auch für
arbeitsplätze
das ist schwer abzuschätzen moment noch
hilft ja die kurzarbeit aber deutschland
ist ein exportland jeder vierte
arbeitsplatz hängt am geschäft mit dem
ausland
ja und die aussichten sind düster der
außenhandel rechnet damit dass es in den
kommenden monaten sogar noch dicker
kommt das liegt auch daran dass mit
einer globalen blitz erholung einfach
kaum jemand rechnet und wem es
wirtschaftlich schlecht geht der muss
eben sparen und wird erstmal nicht mehr
wie gewohnt ware aus deutschland kaufen
dabei sind die branchen ganz
unterschiedlich betroffen
hart erwischt hat es den maschinenbau
den größten einbruch aber hatte die
autoindustrie profitieren konnte die
pharma branche ihre arzneimittel waren
im april sogar gefragter als noch vor
einem jahr die hoffnung bleibt dass sich
der experten mit der wirtschaft erholt
und kommendes jahr schon wieder in
richtung normalität marschiert das
scheint zwar nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ausgeschlossen ist das aber nicht
herzlichen dank nach frankfurt auch die
eu sucht nach wegen der wirtschaft aus
der krise zu helfen und wie immer wenn
es um viel geld geht ist eine einigung
schwierig die finanzminister haben heute
eine annäherung versucht bislang ohne
ergebnis
auf dem tisch liegt unter anderem an 750
milliarden euro teures paket der eu
kommission
si
will dass die empfänger einen großteil
der hilfen nicht zurückzahlen müssen
mehrere länder wehren sich dagegen und
halten auch die summen für zu hoch unser
nächstes thema heute deutschlands
höchstes gericht hat heute beurteilt -in
einem streit zwischen innenminister
horst seehofer und der afd
seehofer war die partei 2018 scharf
angegangen in einem interview dass er
auf die webseite des innenministeriums
stellte unter anderem kritisierte er das
verhalten der afg als staats zersetzend
das bundesverfassungsgericht erklärte
heute als parteipolitiker darf seehofer
so etwas sagen aber als minister muss
eher neutral bleiben christoph schneider
september 2018 bundespräsident
steinmeier verurteilte die
ausländerfeindlichen ausschreitungen in
chemnitz wenig später will die afg
fraktion im bundestag über den haushalt
des bundespräsidenten diskutieren
es wird polemischen emotional horst
seehofer äußert sich wenig später zur
afd
in einem interview mit der dpa die
stellen sich gegen diesen staat da
können sie tausendmal sagen sie sind
demokraten
das haben sie am dienstag im bundestag
miterleben können mit dem frontalangriff
auf den bundespräsidenten das ist für
unseren staat hoch gefährlich das ist
starts zersetzend gut zwei wochen steht
dieses interview auch auf der
internetseite des innenministeriums
dagegen klagt die afg vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht mit erfolg der
zweite senat des höchsten deutschen
gerichts übrigens letztmals unter dem
vorsitz des langjährigen
gerichtspräsidenten andreas vosskuhle
gibt der afg nun recht die zulässigkeit
der öffentlichkeitsarbeit der
bundesregierung endet also dort wo
werbung für oder einflussnahme gegen
einzelne im politischen wettbewerb
stehende parteien oder personen beginnt
die afg sieht sich in ihrem klage
vorwurf bestätigt
es ist eine homepage der regierung
und wenn herr seehofer da parteipolitik
betreibt in form einer massiv
diskriminierenden abwertung dann geht
das nicht
fazit des urteils auch bundesminister
dürfen in reden oder interviews den
politischen gegner attackieren auch
polternd doch in ihrer rolle als
minister sind sie amtsträger und zur
neutralität und damit zur zurückhaltung
verpflichtet und damit darf auch
seehofer die alv die zwar weiter als
staats ersetzen bezeichnen aber eben
nicht in seiner eigenschaft als minister
auf der internetseite des ministeriums
die trennlinie zwischen politischer
meinungskampf und regierungshandeln ist
jetzt klar gezogen
das corona virus hat die komplette welt
im griff und dass es nach wie vor so und
die zahlen der whu sind alarmierend
immer noch und gerade jetzt noch nie gab
es so viele nachgewiesene infektionen
wie aktuell auf die ganze welt bezogen
und besonders auffällig in südamerika in
europa und in deutschland gehen die
zahlen zurück was das konkret bedeutet
und was hinter diesen zahlen steckt
erläutert antworten kurschilgen
frankfurt heute nachmittag die menschen
strömen in die innenstadt bilder fast
wie vor der korona pandemie der alltag
kehrt immer mehr zurück aber das virus
ist noch da von entwarnung kann keine
rede sein
also ich fürchte so lange dieses virus
auf der welt sein unwesen treibt werden
wir weiterhin vorsichtsmaßnahmen
ergreifen müssen
denn die bevölkerung hat noch keine
ausreichende immunität um diese pandemie
um dieses virus stoppen zu können
deshalb werden wir noch lange zeit mit
diesen abstandsregeln zurecht kommen
müssen und auch mit den masken keine
entwarnung aber die entwicklung ist
positiv auch wenn die zahl der
neuinfektionen wieder leicht gestiegen
ist entsteht der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 360 menschen neu
angesteckt das heißt 7489 patienten
kämpfen aktuell noch mit der krankheit
corvette 19
die große welle ist vorbei wie dieser
kurven verlauf der pandemie zeigt
rund ein drittel der landkreise in
deutschland sind sogar komplett corona
frei es sieht so aus als ob gerade die
absage von großveranstaltungen und das
einhalten der abstandsregeln und weil
die weiteren jene maßnahmen entscheidend
dafür sind dass wir eben bisher keinen
weiteren anstieg gesehen haben und
deswegen wird fleißig gelockert
thüringen reduziert die kontakt
beschränkungen weiter mecklenburg
vorpommern erlaubt die volle auslastung
der hotelbetten auch bars und kneipen
sollen wieder öffnen und virologen waren
weitere lockerungen sind dann gefährlich
wenn sie geschlossene räume betreffen wo
relativ viele menschen zusammenkommen
und möglicherweise auch keine masken
tragen da wäre ich sehr vorsichtig und
zurückhaltend auf großveranstaltungen
werden wir also wohl noch lange
verzichten müssen vielleicht sogar bis
es einen impfstoff gibt und das kann
noch dauern
und dann kommen wir in der sendung zum
großen thema sommerurlaub und da wollen
die balearen jetzt wieder mitmischen
mallorca und die anderen balearen inseln
lassen wieder touristen einreisen ab
nächste woche fast 11.000 urlauber aus
deutschland dürfen kommen weil hier die
infektionszahlen niedrig sind
das ganze eine art probebetrieb für
flughäfen hotels und strände damit in
der sommersaison auch alles klappt
anselm stern berichtet mallorca
wunderschön und leer wegen der virus
krise doch schon ganz bald dürfen hier
wieder touristen baden und zwar die dass
ganz besonders gerne tun
deutsche touristen sollen hier
entspannen auf probe sozusagen aus
deutschland kommen die meisten urlauber
zu uns und die pandemie zahlen dort sind
ähnlich wie bei uns nämlich derzeit
niedrig bei den neuansteckungen und so
können ab montag am noch so lehren
flughafen in palma wieder touristen
rannten
hier wird dann unter anderem fieber
gemessen wer keins hat muss nicht in
quarantäne sondern darf urlaub machen
also das pilotprojekt beginnt jetzt am
15 juni das heißt man kann heute nacht
noch seine flüge buchen und kann sich
sogar noch auf diese flüge ein buchen
und dann am nächsten montag
nach mallorca fliegen die prozesse sind
entsprechend angepasst vor ort das heißt
urlaub wird dieses jahr sehr viel
ruhiger sein ruhiger und ganz anders
urlaub voller antivirus regeln mit den
deutschen gästen wollen etwa hotels bars
und restaurants ausprobieren ob hygiene
und abstands maßnahmen wirken und der
testlauf soll hoffnung vermitteln
wir müssen sicherstellen dass mallorca
ein sicheres reiseziel bleibt tourismus
mitten in der pandemie bleibt ein risiko
und doch die gäste sind eben auch so
wichtig für so viele einheimische die
inseln leben vom tourismus es gibt sonst
keine große industrie die ihr leben
sozusagen von sonne und mehr sonne und
mehr unbeschwert genießen darauf hoffen
die insulaner und die deutschen test
touristen
einer dessen tod zum symbol für
diskriminierung und gewalt durch die us
polizei wurde wird heute beigesetzt in
seiner heimatstadt houston nehmen in
diesen minuten
familie und freunde bei einer privaten
trauerfeier abschied von george freut
sein schicksal hat tausende menschen
weltweit auf die straßen getrieben
in den usa geht derweil der aufschrei
nach gerechtigkeit und veränderung im
polizeisystem weiter in vielen städten
wird auch heute wieder demonstriert
zurück nach deutschland der vw konzern
steckt in erheblichen turbulenzen corona
krise diesen skandal umbau zum
autohersteller und jetzt noch ein
machtkampf zwischen konzernchef und
aufsichtsrat das ergebnis vorstandschef
herbert diess darf im amt bleiben
verliert aber einen teil seiner macht
und muss die leitung der kernmarke vw
abgeben kritik gibt es unter anderem
wegen problemen beim neuen golf 8 und
auch beim batteriebetriebenen
hoffnungsträger id3 läuft es nicht rund
wer hat denn im hause volkswagen jetzt
tatsächlich das sagen das ist die frage
nach wolfsburg an peter kunz genannt
hallo ihr haben naja der chef das bleibt
erstmal der chef das ist herbert diess
aber ihn wird jetzt mehr auf die finger
geschaut er hat gezeigt dass er immer
gut ist für große worte was den wandel
bei volkswagen angeht manchmal wird er
auch die falschen worte aber es fehlen
noch die großen taten die sichtbar
großen taten dafür häufen sich fehler
das erste digitale zukunft auto mit
elektroantrieb
der erwähnte id3 der kommt nicht aus dem
knick auch weil programmierer fehlen und
dies managementstil stößt vielen auf mit
dem starken betriebsrats-chef liegt er
sowieso eine dauerfehde herbert diess
hat in zwei jahren viel druck bei
volkswagen aufgebaut jetzt wendet er
sich gegen ihn noch hat der volkswagen
weil alle box allerdings die
unterstützung der hauptaktionäre der
wichtigen familien porsche und piëch
aber die könnte er auch leicht verlieren
wenn er nicht besser und schnell liefert
mit der kunst seit der erfolgs burg
herzlichen dank und wir bleiben noch im
moment beim thema auto die luft in
deutschlands städten ist besser geworden
im letzten jahr haben nur noch 25 städte
den stickstoffdioxid grenzwerte
überschritten 2018 waren es noch 57
maßnahmen wie tempolimits fahrverbote
und mehr saubere autos seien der grund
dafür sagt das umweltbundesamt die
korona krise habe übrigens die
schadstoffwerte noch weiter sinken
lassen
im missbrauchsfall von münster könnte es
noch mehr opfer geben zwei väter haben
anzeige erstattet weil ihre söhne von
verdächtigen in dem fall unsittlich
berührt worden seien sagt ein
polizeisprecher
die ermittler waren bisher davon
ausgegangen dass die mutmaßlichen täter
mindestens drei jungen missbraucht haben
diskriminierung zermürbt sagte ein mann
der sich damit auskennt auskennen muss
der leiter der
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
bernhard franke er spricht von versuchen
menschen auszusortieren immer öfter aus
rassistischen motiven aber auch wegen
ihrem geschlecht einer behinderung oder
der sexuellen orientierung
die opfer dürften nicht alleine gelassen
werden heute hat er seinen jahresbericht
vorgelegtes berichtet romanesco war
für manolya war es ein alptraum ihren
vollen namen will die türkischstämmige
frau nicht nennen sie wohnt mit ihrem
freund zusammen
dem vermieter passte das nicht
diskriminierende beschimpfungen
beschuldigungen die folge bei themen wie
falsche mülltrennung im haus er hat mich
dafür verantwortlich gemacht er meinte
es ist wir sind hier nicht in anatolien
es ist ein ordentliches haus mein freund
solle sich eine neue freundin suchen und
er würde den mietvertrag dann
entsprechend umschreiben ein fall von
vielen
die antidiskriminierungsstelle
registriert mehr beschwerden vergangenes
jahr betrafen die meisten fälle mit 33
prozent die ethnische herkunft 29
prozent das geschlecht 26% behinderungen
für den leiter der einrichtung gerade
die zunahme rassistischer meldungen
besorgniserregend der handlungsdruck
groß
wir sehen ihn in den gesetzlichen
regelungen dass diese verbessert werden
müssen wir sehen ihn aber auch dass das
beratungsangebot für menschen die sich
diskriminiert sehen dass das
beratungsangebot dort verbessert werden
muss manolya fand eine beratungsstelle
speziell für wohn belange meist geht es
um benachteiligungen bei der
wohnungssuche diskriminierende
nachbarschaftskonflikte aber immer
häufiger team die aufgabe betroffene zu
beraten bei manolya führte das zum
erfolg sie erstritten unterlassungs
urteil seitdem ist es ruhiger geworden
und dann schauen wir jetzt noch auf
einen spektakulären fund des zolls in
polen der hat dort drei tonnen kokain
aus dem verkehr gezogen versteckt in
tiefgefrorenen ananas mark gesamtwert
unfassbare 670 millionen euro
der stoff kam aus ecuador über hamburg
nach polen und war offenbar für mehrere
europäische länder
drei verdächtige wurden festgenommen
vorsicht vor tiefgefrorene man anders
mag jetzt kommt der sport mit christina
ich habe gleich mal eine trennung alfred
schröder ist nicht mehr trainer des
fußball bundesligisten tsg hoffenheim zu
groß war wohl der schatten seines
vorgängers julian nagelsmann die
sofortige vertragsauflösung mit dem
niederländer soll einvernehmlich sei der
zeitpunkt der trennung von alfred
schröder kurz vor saisonende überrascht
hoffenheim hat als tabellensiebter noch
chancen auf die europa league
ausschlaggebend sind angeblich
differenzen bei der zukunftsplanung nach
dem für uns und auch vertretern klar war
dass es im sommer eine andere besetzung
geben wird haben wir uns dann
entschlossen gemeinsam diesen schritt
einfach vorzuziehen
schröder hatte im vergangenen sommer als
nachfolger von julian nagelsmann den
trainer job übernommen in dessen
fußstapfen konnte er aber nie wirklich
treten auf glanzvolle siege wie gegen
dortmund folgten teilweise krachende
niederlagen jetzt soll bis saisonende
ein sechsköpfiges trainerteam aus den
eigenen reihen übernehmen das kapitel
schröder ist jedenfalls beendet
vierter tag beim finalturnier um die
deutsche basketball meisterschaft in
münchen zweiter sieg für ludwigsburg in
einer überaus spannenden partie der
gruppe b gegen frankfurt setzten sich
die ludwigsburger am ende knapp mit 80
77 durch und zwei dfb pokal abende
stehen bevor und nach saarbrücken gegen
leverkusen heute will morgen eintracht
frankfurt bei den bayern in münchen das
scheinbar unmögliche möglich machen
sie suchen wir noch ihren pokal modus
der die frankfurter in den letzten vier
jahren dreimal ins halbfinale und
zweimal ins finale gebracht hatte 2018
gewannen sie sogar das endspiel gegen
die bayern
jede mannschaft
ist in gewissen momenten auch zu knacken
dass der eintracht tore gegen die bayern
gelingen hat sie auch in dieser saison
gezeigt doch mit platz elf in der liga
liegt frankfurt dennoch hinter den
erwartungen zurück haben jetzt sozialem
gegen bayern in zwei spielen sieben tore
erzielt ich glaube dass wir da auch
möglichkeiten haben sie bei standard
situationen vielleicht auch wieder zu
überraschen und ko spiele liegen den
frankfurtern das haben sie in den
letzten jahren in pokal und europa
league bewiesen wenn es um alles geht
sind sie da ja zuversicht ist es immer
gut stimmt schüler kalenderspruch noch
mal wenn du dieses tages hat sich nicht
riskieren gucken wir aufs wetter regen
und später gewitter prägen morgen das
wetter im süden details für das
komplette land erfahren sie gleich von
intel
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal 21
uhr 45 mit dem kollegen claus kleber von
uns danke für ihr großes interesse gerne
bis morgen und in allen erstmal einen
angenehmen dienstagabend
[Musik]
ein schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tiefer luftdruck
über dem alpenraum will nicht weichen
dieses tief hängt dort fest und
schaufelt weiterhin schauer und auch
teilweise gewitter morgen im
tagesverlauf nach deutschland
ja und dann gibt es ja noch dieses tief
bei den britischen inseln das wandert in
den süden richtung spanien und lenkt
dann in den nächsten tagen wenn es dort
angekommen ist wärmere luft zu uns
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es im
süden deutschlands ziemlich viele wolken
und es regnet hier zwischen alpenrand
und bayerischer wald in der mitte gibt
es schauer nach norden gibt es nur
wenige wolken und an der ostsee ist es
sternenklar temperaturen sinken auf 7
grad in schleswig holstein und 14 grad
im rhein-main-gebiet ja morgen dann vor
allem der nordhälfte viel sonnenschein
zwischen der ostsee und den
nordfriesischen inseln ansonsten schauer
vom emsland bis zur mitte und im süden
noch mehr wolken und noch mehr regen vor
allem im süden gewitter vom
berchtesgadener land richtung donau
ansonsten grau in grau mit viel regen
temperaturen 22 grad an der elbe und 14
grad an den alpen an fronleichnam
bekommen wir schauen dann vor allem im
osten und dann später im westen bis 23
grad und dann machen die temperaturen
satz nach oben 30 grad am freitag und
samstag heftige gewitter ein schöner
abend